il faut un peu de hauteur pour mieux
prendre conscience de l'ampleur des
travaux
une inspection menée par catherine dont
le constat est sans appel niveau des
risques peu d'usure donc faudrait
peut-être songer à aller à l'échangé des
drisses des poulies et dévoue à la
renouveler un carénage est effectué sans
compter l'achat d'une remorque des
dépenses faramineuses qui oblige
l'équipage a bricolé un maximum de
réparer faire du matériel un rafistolage
qui dure depuis trop longtemps
bientôt quatre ans que douvan le
surprise entièrement féminin n'a pas
subi de travaux majeurs malgré les
sponsors les finances ne suivent plus
la question s'est même posé arrêté ou
poursuivre l'aventuré
il ya plein de gens sur l'eau qui nous
apprécient qui nous encouragent qui sont
épatés et je le suis la première à est
épaté de tout ce qu'on arrive à faire
contre filles on arrive à faire
l'entretien de notre bateau ont fait
nous prépare nos régates
on s'occupe de tout de façon autonome
les filles ont besoin de dix mille euros
pour remettre à flot l'embarcation
elles ont déjà collecté le tiers de la
somme et il leur reste un mois pour
atteindre leur objectif les
compétitrices espère ainsi se remettre
rapidement l'entraînement avant les
premières et kate de l'année